welcome to this video playing dimitrios
from the US dimitrios okay yeah I simply
like this opening when they give me the
bishop pair all the time I like the
limbs black as well of course but with
white at least I know what to do I want
to vary a bit i played lots of the
sameish recently tons of that already on
video I want to vary a bit with this
Quincy to move the classical variation
which in a way is the complete opposite
of them the sameish keeps the pawn
structure intact b6 yes this is a funny
move that recently had been recommended
by Maya who pawns lidar 3 is not the
prescribed antidote but I want I don't
want to spend a huge huge time on that
to keep it simple here now this looks
like a transposition to them into the c5
line for c5 and quite a good way for
white as some I have not played a 3
which normally needs to be played to get
the bishop back from before to take on
c5 nothing brilliant this achievement
but something that is quite helpful ok
um can I somehow my prolly not let's
play quick I was wondering if I can
punish his move order somehow
like attacking the deep on how can I do
that it's that way maybe I want I want
to preserve this Bishop that would be
would be nice Bishop g3 and possibly
keep it down okay let's go back here
keep this piece if I do something like
windy to where he has to play a fire
which is not really great question is
how bad is it ready it is not brilliant
but I came it I think it's worth it were
it's worth provoking okay so he wanted
to avoid this okay going to take and now
play this position where at least i have
gained something in terms of porn
structure Quincy six is a move hmm I
want we should have won if possible a
black is still very very solid this
double porn is not the end of the world
but it's something that long term can be
a problem frame chan
check especially in some minor peas and
games this this pawn structure can prove
costly they wants to take and after
Queen takes play 94 possibly i can take
on e5 though okay so it's not happening
sorry well it's not a big problem or any
problem for once I wasn't totally slow
yeah but I can just give this check here
right and then go from there check why
is it in fact not much used to give the
check
we're not totally sure if I want to
allow him to take that on c3m and two
might be a problem and let's let's just
reliably protect that it's probably
better to take it with the Queen all the
time the check is not leading to that
much after the check king age seven I
really don't I didn't see a great move
now that I can play I can play Quincy
seven or something maybe that's a better
end game for me but I wasn't sure after
the capture on one c3 and 97 just trying
to protect the whole thing efore has
killed his bishop on b7 so it's not a
huge achievement oh he loves me to trade
that okay Queen d1 just trying to get
rid of the Queen's if not i will come up
to deform improve the position to d2 for
example Queen before Queen d2 things
like that
the minor piece endgame should be and
maybe maybe still to see to what yeah
it's not really okay don't mind you gain
a little bit of space there before obvi
should be too i can just improve a bit
more let's go before what is the way to
make progress c5 would be nice yarn I
day for and c5 maybe I'd give some mad
it gives md5 but there is I need to do
something I cannot just was just sitting
around I'm not going to win this okay
yeah I'm not sure about c5 really to be
honest is it is it giving me much maybe
not maybe that's not enough it's really
not enough maybe
but take that F Phi D and then approach
approach the pawn so this is winning the
pawn v5 I go if or maybe he can come
around attack the c-4 pawn don't tell me
there is some some crazy breakthrough
stuff going on so h4 just take it let's
go edge form that is crazy breakthrough
stuff going on I did not take that Wow
ways sometimes I really wonder what I'm
doing jack
check
don't really know how to win this stuff
if it's possible at all thats that's
probably not not doing much good maybe
had such a draw already somehow by
repetition check check black forfeits
aren't I oh yeah that wasn't really
deserved victory right oh why on earth
yeah why on earth did I take one g4 of
course I was take on g4 nah yeah of
course g4 I need to take and I was
mentioning the breakthrough ideas yeah
just take it and then go from there I
mean I don't know if I win here probably
i do but um yeah well g3 I can I
actually take it yeah I can actually
take again you can he can go without
it's not that's not fatal i can i can
keep the Jeep on with the king and then
my opponents will win ah very trick here
maybe maybe I already should have gone
for this c5 business yeah and I wasn't
sure if this is enough to win I wasn't
really sure i was thinking it takes and
I don't know is this winning this kind
of thing I mean I have a hard time to
ever push the pawn to c6 and it's it's
somehow not clear what I'm doing yeah
maybe this isn't really something that
that
that leaves much track and here I'm
really unsure if there is something that
you can do maybe a five yeah here I'm
winning this pawn well I a very tricky
Evan but at the end after I had allowed
this this is funny business I'm probably
maybe I can still go here because now it
happened in the game right he went there
check yeah this is really interesting
can wide win this a computer is very
optimistic but this could be one of
those positions where the computer is
not right because there's maybe no way
forward besides the porn and whatnot
check I mean I was basically shuffling a
[ __ ] here and looking for stuff in the
meantime but I couldn't really find
anything he was walking away no I'm
really winning I'm to just a little
trick yeah very difficult i really don't
know it was very stupid that allowed the
pawn to g3 because of those breakthrough
of ideas well ok thanks for watching